bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui quatre voies pour débattre
des stratégies des partis politiques qui
regarde tous vers les élections
régionales de décembre est bien sûr vers
la présidentielle de 2017 avec sur ce
plateau
sébastien martins conseiller
départemental et président du grand
chalon pour les républicains bonjour
bonjour stéphanie vote vous êtes la
porte parole régionale d'europe écologie
les verts
bonjour à vous nous sourds je viens
odoul secrétaire nouveau secrétaire du
front national de l'yonne bonjour
bonjour et fadila khattabi
vice-présidente socialiste du conseil
régional
bonjour à vous et chez vous vous pouvez
réagir comme d'habitude sur les réseaux
sociaux twitter et sur notre site
internet dans l'article consacré à
l'émission
alors une question très simple pour
commencer un peu ironie aussi qui est
républicain ici stéphanie modde vous
êtes république et bien sûr je suis
républicaine la république si ce qui
fonde notre engagement en politique
voilà donc je vois venir voter aux
questions suivantes
après mois coûte et je suis plutôt que
vous êtes tous des républicains nous
sommes tous des républicains dans une
danse ont pu réalité politique après bon
le nom le nom je dirais importe peu le
fonds n'a pas changé voilà donc c'est
l'ump
voilà c'était contre 20 seulement des
républiques bien sûr que c'était contre
nous depuis quelques mois que ce soit
deux rangs de la gauche ou de la droite
je dirais qu'on nous taxe d'anti
républicain d'anti démocrate de
fascistes nous avons subi toutes les
insultes depuis quelques mois ce qui est
quand scandaleux à l'égard déjà des
responsables et des candidats du front
national mais surtout à l'égard des
millions d'électeurs
finalement qui prend nos idées qui se
sentent insultés chaque jour mais sur
l'appellation républicain qui est
finalement une escroquerie
intellectuelle et politique de nicolas
sarkozy qui a fait un petit tour de
passe-passe cosmétiques
finalement pour essayer de laver son
bilan qui est calamiteux parce que son
bilan il est foncièrement anti
républicain il est antirépublicain
j'irai qu'il a il a souillé la valeur
les valeurs de la république la liberté
puisque notre
pas de souveraineté pour la france donc
sans souveraineté nous n'aurons pas de
liberté l'égalité puis que la seule
égalité pour les français c'est
l'égalité devant le chômage
et puis la fraternité finalement qui
tombe à la poubelle puisqu'avec la
montée du communautarisme on le voit
qu'il n'ya plus de fraternité et je
n'oublie pas aussi la laïcité qui
menaçait chaque jour dans le
fondamentalisme islamiste
réponse je ne suis pas réagir à la
stratégie de victimisation du du front
national ou bien à la répétition
d'éléments de langage qui sont fournies
par le siège à nanterre
alors quand moi je suis gêné parce que
ça vous fait rire mais je préfère la
réponse de de madame mode qui affirme qu
effectivement chacun républicain qui a
pas lieu à polémiquer sur le nom d'un
parti politique le visage du terme
républicains avaient utilisés avaient
été utilisés par d'autres partis
auparavant là parce que c'est nous parce
que c'est nicolas sarkozy on veut en
faire une
une polémique qui n'a pas lieu d'être
pour avoir vainement parce que c'était
le je crois que c'était le moyen de
montrer aussi qu'on passait sur un
nouveau départ qu'il ya des
préoccupations auxquelles on doit
répondre qu'ils sont les préoccupations
des français et que ya la volonté de
construire un nouveau projet pour les
élections de 2017
c'est ça l'intérêt c'est ça qui
intéresse franchement les françaises et
les français vous savez les affaires
internes des partis
quand vous regardez le nombre
d'adhérents qui peut y avoir dans chacun
de nos partis ici autour de la table
vous croyez vraiment que c'est ça eq
intéresse les habitants de chalon sur
saône de dijon d'auxerre de nevers moi
je crois pas franchement je pense que ce
qu'ils veulent c'est savoir sur ce met
au boulot et si on a des propositions
concrètes à faire pour les prochaines
échéances
voilà après le reste les éléments de
langage des uns et des autres sont les
éléments de langage des uns et des
autres familles je suis profondément
bien sûr républicaine je crois que la
république elle est une et indivisible
la république appartient à l'ensemble
des citoyens et donc je pense que c'est
une stratégie de la part de nicolas
sarkozy mais je crois que on est
habitués tous les dix quinze ans il
débaptise rebaptise donc on est rpr ump
aujourd'hui les républicains
donc ces essais pour essayer de faire
peau neuve
mais je suis désolé le renouveau passe
par le renouveau
idée par le renouveau également de la
classe politique or aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on constate on constate qu'on
prend les mêmes et on recommence
ils n'ont pas je le dis pas d'idées sans
vouloir polémiquer puisque la thématique
de la première convention c'est l'islam
et en plus s'il vous plaît à huis clos
comme s'il fallait débattre à huis clos
quand on parle de la laïcité donc voilà
je pense que c'est les français ne sont
pas dupes c'est pas parce qu'on change
de nom que le parti est nouveau ce qui
exclut ce profil suivant c'est la
volonté nicolas sarkozy c'est de
redevenir président de la république est
ce que dans la vème république c'est
faisable
est-ce que c'est conforme à l'esprit
finalement de la vème république et est
ce que vous pensez que ça c'est une
bonne idée de revenir quand on a été
battu à une élection dans une campagne
très dure et très personnalisés est ce
qu'on fait de la politique pour rappeler
mais appliqué des schémas de cours
d'histoire je crois pas je pense que la
politique on l'écrit on l'a fait on la
vit il n'y a pas de règles pas de règle
donc si nous que la sarkozie alors qu'on
apprenait la délinquance politique ait
envie d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il y aura une primaire de
bureau politique des républicains a acté
un comité d'organisation se met en place
avec toutes les tendances représentées
il y aura une primaire que le meilleur
gagne et la primaire que le meilleur
projet voilà c'est ça c'est pas une
leçon d'histoire leur tour nicolas
sarkozy oui panneau où l'art elles sont
liées oui moi je suis assez surprise
parce que bon effectivement même sur
l'organisation de primaires il semble
que nicolas sarkozy est pas tout à fait
partant pour ça j'ai l'impression que ça
lui plaît pas beaucoup donc même pays ou
party les républicains voyez je veux le
même père et public et aux convois se
tromper un petit peu non au delà la
plaisanterie je crois que y'a pas grand
chose qui a changé effectivement mois ce
qui doit nous préoccuper en tant que
parti politique qui sait je m'intéresse
c'est ce qui se passe chez nous c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est moi
sariel débats de ce que de ce qui
devrait nous préoccuper tous ensemble
actuellement les politiques c'est le
premier parti de france et l'abstention
c'est comment on fait pour faire renouer
l'envi de participer à la vie politique
à la cité nos concitoyens voilà donc je
pense que ce n'est pas ces changements
non qui sont effectivement des effets
d'annoncé moi j'utilise aucune envie de
polémiquer là dessus
franchement ce qui intéresse les
français c'est l'implication citoyenne
comment renouvelle le pacte social en
france comment on fait intéressé la
politique comme on indique nothing nos
concitoyens beaucoup plus dans les
décisions politiques
comment les ramène finalement à ne plus
considérer des politiques comme comme
impuissants face à ce qui leur arrive
face à la montée du sud du chômage et
puis je crois qu'il faut par contre
alors là je me porte en fout on commence
à peine de discuter et on a déjà le
parti-pris moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réinstaurer la solidarité et ne
pas parler effectivement de ce qui peut
scinder et de débats qui sont fous puis
dire voilà la laïcité c'est ce qui nous
réunit
et voilà je trouve vraiment commencé à
commencer un débat en parlant de l'islam
de la façon dont six filles je trouve ça
pas correct donc on doit comprendre quoi
que vous avez peur que on retombe très
rapidement dans ce qui a marqué des
campagnes politiques précédents je pense
qu'il ya vraiment urgence à à redonner
confiance aux français
alors ça peut paraître voilà mais c'est
redonner confiance et comment donc le
renouveau des partis politiques ça passe
effectivement par un renouvellement de
ses cadres aussi ça c'est évident mais
aussi sur la caisse qui fondent notre
république qu'est ce qui fonde nos
fondamentaux
comment on peut on peut si on parle de
politique nationale comment on peut
enfin vrai pour pour plus de justice
sociale
quand on voit encore l'évasion fiscale
en france actuellement
là il ya un vrai levier d'un vrai levier
qui peut mettre tout le monde d'accord
voilà le front pour arrêter cette
évasion fiscale qui nous coûtent des
milliards d'euros alors que pendant le
même temps les collectivités locales
sont obligées de se serrer la ceinture
moi ça c'est des vrais sujets de société
et là je pense que ça peut ça peut
intéresser vraiment les gens plus près
de 6me campagne a commencé
je voudrais juste rebondir par rapport
effectivement à nicolas sarkozy
on va pas débattre toute l'émission les
deux duos formés mais c'est quand même
important ce qui est quand même
extraordinaire c'est qu'il a été battu
en 2010 et en 2000 par dans 2012
il a été donc battu il revient et il a
pris la tête du pouvoir non pas bien sûr
pour servir la france mais on sait parce
que il a une revanche à prendre une
revanche à prendre sur le président de
la république donc déjà c'est très mal
parti
je veux dire son bilan effectivement
comme l'a souligné madame mode
catastrophique
il a mis à mal les services je termine
pour le foot c'est la réalité
il a été battu ça vous ne pouvez pas le
nier il a milité abadie osé en juge
comme ça il a essayé bien de ce qui ne
se résout à billère de laquelle elle
habite à lille a conduit la france non
pas vers le redressement mais vers le
déclin il a mis à mal nos services
publics avec la fameuse lg dp1 foncière
vous avez sommes ensemble rendre justice
aux affaires laissez moi me parler de
mouvement que ça vous ça vous dérange
mes propos mais c'est la réalité
le luxe de nous avec l'un il a continué
bien sûr qu'il n'est pas je le dis
responsables de la crise qui était au
départ une crise financière qui est
devenue une crise économique il a géré
la crise comme il a pu en tous les cas
il n'a pas pris les bonnes mesures pour
gérer cette crise dans la mesure où il a
continué juste eu sur cette mesure quand
même qui est quand même importante farde
chez nicolas sarkozy c'est de maintenir
le bouclier le bouclier fiscal en faveur
des plus aisés alors que les caisses de
l'état étaient vides
le premier ministe de l'ecoop l'époque
monsieur fillon a dit je suis à la tête
d'un parti en faillite il là mais il l'a
dit et pour autant et pour autant que la
villa belza millionnaire c1 et
laissez-moi termine écoutez vous n'êtes
pas très républicain pour le coup en ne
laissant pas les autres s'exprimer mais
je vais vous voyez vous appelez vous
voilà vous êtes républicain mais blessé
pas les autres et l'opposition
s'exprimer je suis en train de danser
dans ce mélange d'intuition
vous savez on avance et c'est
effectivement en faveur des plus aisés
et cetera
et donc aujourd'hui il se présente il se
présente pour repartir tout le monde le
sait pour les élections présidentielles
sauf que voilà il n'a pas fait mea culpa
il n'a pas analysé non plus son bilan
qui était catastrophique et il revient
donc les français aujourd'hui ne sont
pas dupes en plus de cela il ne cesse de
diviser la france je le dis ça n'est pas
bon pour la république et pour la
cohésion de notre pays
c'est assez amusant ce plateau de voir
enfin amusant et pathétique à la fois de
voir l'opposition de façade sur jouer
entre nos deux représentants l'ump s ans
je jouais a repris depuis qu'ils
s'entendent pas trop peut-être mais
finalement ils partagent le même bilan
ils ont appliqué exactement les mêmes
politiques ce sont les mêmes soumission
à l'égard de bruxelles sont les mêmes
soumission à l'égard des lobbys à
l'égard du qatar l'égard de l'arabie
saoudite c'est exactement la même
politique depuis trente ans voilà et là
on nous fait un petit numéro
d'opposition stérile
ce que j'aimerais que j'aimerais dire su
alors sur nicolas sarkozy là où je
rejoindrai madame c'est peut-être le
seul point c'est quoi il a été battu il
a été battu sèchement le 6 mai 2012 et
les français ils n'ont pas voté pour
françois hollande
ils n'ont pas voté pour les socialistes
ils ont projeté fait main du ca a été un
vote de large est terminée dans dix
minutes
on va moi je le sais pas non plus un
petit peu le front national quand même
et des électeurs qui aimeraient aussi
connaître mes positions
même quand vos candidats ne parle pas
bon et c'est bon ce que j'aimerais dire
sauver le site
ça a été un vote de rejet roger franc et
massif
voilà les français n'ont pas voulu du
socialiste ils ont voulu rejeter une
politique et surtout un comportement n
un comportement un comportement indigne
et honteux qui a souillé la république
pendant cinq ans parce que sous nicolas
sarkozy
le chômage a explosé l'immigration
massive et incontrôlée n'a fait que
s'accroître et la sécurité qui devait
être endiguée finalement n'a pas été n'a
pas été légers sont de morale et de
respect ne sont pas des du front
national écouter les français leurs
coûts
les français qui tu disais moi les
conséquences de votre politique laure
nouveau candidat ne s'affiche même pas
en photo ne font aucune réunion fait
plein temps mais attend ses deux matches
contre l'irlande ya vingt ans avant les
dernières élections cantonales dans mon
canton à givry la candidate du front
national ne vient pas voter au deuxième
tour et vous nous donner des leçons de
république en vue alors balayé dont on
attendait là vous me sortez le petit
élément dans votre canton à il est le
canton dans l'yonne où le candidat du
front national finalement deux mois
après mais on devrait avoir été élus
démissionnent son suppléant comme par
hasard ne vais pas elena temps des fêtes
ce serait belle être sérieux la
politique se dise certaine à taux plein
arrivé à voter socialiste
là je ne suis absolument pas d'accord
avec vous d'ailleurs on le voit quand au
moment des dépouillements généralement
lors des dépouillements ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il y ait un report des
voix du front national vert vers la
droite est aujourd'hui justement avec la
ligne dure proposée par nicolas sarkozy
je veux dire en courant après les idées
je le dis très franchement nauséabond du
front national justement même au sein de
votre parti
il y à une scission par rapport à cela
donc c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui il
espère faire une opa sur les électeurs
du front national
en prenant les mêmes thématiques là
aussi il n'a pas fait le bilan passé bon
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'on avait
prévenu par les grandes manoeuvres de
2017 et qu'on est toujours sur les
élites sur l'élection devant d'une
sphère du manioc je vous propose
d'avancer
on va essayer de tenir un plan même si
c'est difficile suis pas certain
padilha ktb un mot sur le congrès du
parti socialiste vous y étiez
est ce que ces tranchées au parti
socialiste est ce qu'il ya une majorité
qui suivent l hymne du gouvernement et
est ce que la minorité accepte d'être la
minorité moi je n'ai pas compris tout à
fait ça vous étiez à poitiers j étais
aussi oui en coulisses c'est pas
exactement comme ça que ça se passe
écoutez j'étais à poitiers il y avait
quand même un enjeu important
l'enjeu c'était de remettre en ordre de
marche le parti pour ce faire il fallait
une clarification au niveau d'une ligne
politique aujourd'hui c'est tranché il y
a eu des débats dans l'ensemble des
fédérations dans toute la france
les militants se sont exprimés
aujourd'hui il ya une ligne claire c'est
la ligne qui du texte motion a proposé
donc soutenu par jean christophe
cambadélis qui a été donc largement voté
puisque à 60%
donc c'est un très bon score les
militants par ce vote est bien exprime
tout soutien au gouvernement puisque les
membres du gouvernement ont soutenu
cette cette motion ont signé cette
motion et avance à bourg balance
novembre christian paul va très bien à
écouter arnaud montebourg il avait la
possibilité je lui que j'aime avant tout
à fait mais il avait la bonne et la
possibilité de venir au congrès il avait
la possibilité de présenter un texte tel
ne fut pas son choix là vous verrez
comment vous avez senti ce faire vous
qu'en ce dimanche matin c'était plutôt
comme une tribune un peu électron libre
il a décidé de se retirer de la vie
politique pour l'instant donc dont acte
je dis que s'il avait pu s'exprimer il
aurait dû venir au congrès et présenter
un texte
stéphanie modde quand vous voyez le
parti socialiste est ce que vous êtes
satisfait nous avons pris effectivement
la décision de ne plus être gouvernement
non pas par rapport à ce qui se passe en
interne au ps inquiet leur leur vie
propre moi je pense en tout cas la
pluralité y compris à l'intérieur des
partis est une nécessité c'est vrai que
ça de mieux effectivement parfois et
notamment chez les verts vous savez bien
mais à des à des grandes campagnes nbc
rex je trouve que c'est sain voilà moi
je préfère avoir des gens à l'intérieur
du parti qui sont minorité mais
respectée dans la minorité qui
représente ça ne peut faire que faire
avancer le débat
ce qui est beaucoup plus inquiétant su
parler de de l'abstention massive mais
ce serait aussi finalement du désintérêt
y compris de militants de sympathisants
au sein même des partis puisque on n'est
quand même pas dans une embellie en
termes d'adhésion quels que soient les
partis cette pièce de 50 % les
républicains c'est plutôt ça qui me
préoccupe
après nous effectivement il ya eu quand
même quelques abandons qui nous ont
beaucoup marqué je pense notamment à
l'abandon de la taxe poids lourds qui
était quand même là l'occasion de
pouvoir remettre 3 milliards d'euros de
recettes qui nous aurait été bien utile
dans nos politiques y compris nos
politiques régionales
le dr voilà c'est quand même une
politique régionale qui pâtit là parce
qu'on n'a pas eues on s'est pas donné
les moyens
yasar ya le cic le 6e ça partait d'un
tome bons principes d'un accord de
confiance on voit bien qu accorde
confiance il passe pas donc en fait les
grosses entreprises notamment qui sont
principalement bénéficiaires de cette
mesure pour l'instant ne jouent pas le
jeu en termes de l'emploi il y en a on
aurait besoin s'est investie en même
temps quand vous voyez ségolène royal
hier venir signer un certain nombre de
contrats sur la transition énergétique
c'est plus vous ça n'est plus les
écologistes qui porte le dossier
environnemental d'une femme nous avons
toujours des députés qui sont
extrêmement présents sur la loi de
transition ou non nient pas mais on a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup d'élus que
ce soit des élus locaux d'église
régionaux ou des députés qui lui assure
que quand on regarde qui vraiment est
actif sur les amendements sur les
propositions loi qui remettent aussi
quand on a la droite au sénat qui dit à
l'éolien en ont finalement va reculer
sur l'éolien et m'a effectivement qui
est qui vient à la rescousse et qui
vient redonner en dix ans ici l'éolien
il en faut beaucoup il en faut partout
sur le territoire
en regardant effectivement permettant à
pour tous mais voilà c'est bien des
écologistes on a tout notre toute nue
tard c'est la question j'avais envie de
vous poser la question que valeur c'est
est ce que vous êtes tous républicains
moi j'ai envie de vous demander avant la
conférence sur le maniema qui va se
passer à la trappe des années où est ce
que vous êtes tous préoccupés par
l'environnement et l'écologie
sébastien bach la préoccupation pour
l'environnement à l'écologie mais je
pense que vous l'aviez des discours elle
doit passer par les actes et par la
déclinaison d'un certain nombre de
politiques publiques sur les territoires
nous c'est ce qu'on fait à
l'agglomération chalonnaise suppose que
c'est ce qui se fait ailleurs aussi donc
là dessus pour nous rendre sur les
doigts d éolien elle l'évoqué stéphanie
modde actuellement mais que l'éolien
puisse faire des propositions à ses
dossiers et je sais pas si elle est
politique parce qu'il ya des
collectivités de droite comme de gauche
qui s'engagent sur ces sujets là donc
par contre que ya un débat sur l'impact
paysager etc
je suis pas un spécialiste de l'éolien
je préfère le dire de suite mais qui
puisse y avoir un débat est-ce que c'est
anormal
parce que vraiment ça pose problème à
ces deux cd vouloir empêcher le
développement de cette filière
d'énergies renouvelables quand on sait
que effectivement la coop maintien qui
va se tenir mieux
à la fin de l'année la conférence sur le
climat s'est vraiment comment se dégager
au maximum d'énergie fossile donc il
faut se donner les moyens
donc effectivement moi je suis ravie je
veux dire le discours écologiste
le fait que l'ensemble des élus
maintenant républicains prennent en
compte cette question de l'environnement
moi je jauge j'en suis ravi il ya encore
une dizaine d'années quinzaine d'années
voilà quand on parlait un peu des trois
fois 20 on nous regardait en disons
c'est quoi ce truc quoi voilà voilà donc
moins d'énergies fossiles plus de
renouvelable et on attend vraiment de
c'était en tout cas de cette fois de la
transition énergétique qui va qui va
être votée là qu'on donne vraiment les
moyens pour à la fois cadre de la
rénovation thermique en france pourquoi
parce que c'est aussi un excellent moyen
est un excellent levier pour l'emploi
local l'impression d'un porte après moi
je décline pas localement lajudie au
niveau du cadre national si on n'a pas
les moyens financiers de lancer bien sûr
allusion aussi énormément de choses qui
se font dans le dos et dans les villes
moi je vous parle du levier national du
front national sommes extrêmement
préoccupés par défense de notre
environnement
et d'ailleurs nous avons monté un
collectif collectif nouvelle écologique
et présidé par un économiste de renom
philippe muray re pourquoi qui rassemble
la nouvelle pourquoi nouvelle
puisqu'elle est exactement parce qu'elle
est très éloignée de l'idéologie
écologiste de nos amis verts finalement
qui qui est politisée qui est totalement
fermé qu'est punitive et finalement qu'
il faut se le dire qui ne sert qu'à une
petite caste d'élus pour obtenir des
postes et des mandats voilà à quoi
servent les verts et les écolos donc
nous au front national nous attachons
nous attachons à nous non non je suis
tout à fait lucide nous attachons nous
attachons à ce que je peux tenir
et ce sera terminé non autant est-ce que
ça regarde l'horloge front national avec
ce collectif avec ce collectif merci
merci mme al khattabi ce que je pourrais
terminer mon propos merci mais je
jouerai pas interrompre une façon de
vous relancer aussi effectivement
j'allais dire si tu as dit fadila
khattabi sur un certain nombre de
questions environnementales le front
national en général votre compte au
conseil régional par exemple sur les
projets éoliens
ça signifie qu sur ces filières là je
vais pas favorable sur les projets
éoliens oui parce qu ils défigurent
l'environnement justement il faut
prendre en considération aussi la vie de
nos concitoyens et non pas purement
l'intérêt comme le fait l'allemagne
d'ailleurs une espèce de d'idéologie de
revenir au charbon alors qu'au final ça
va entraîner des coûts supplémentaires
des impôts et une pollution accrue
voilà on est d'accord que le changement
climatique l'urgence des changements
mais je sais qu'au plaisir parlera bien
sûr c'est une priorité
c'est une priorité mais il faut qu'elles
servent les français voilà et non pas
qu'elle sert une petite caste d'élus
pour tenir des postes et des mandats
vraiment ma sueur sur le front national
pense que vraiment nous n'avons
absolument aucune leçon à recevoir
mais gentil le film nommé team qui ne
siège pas fifty man vous avez à peine
élue au conseil départemental d'hygiène
que vous démissionnez est revenu que là
en plus il me semble quand même une
petite affaire d'emplois fictifs ou
parlement européen de votre parti dont
vous n'êtes pas vous êtes
particulièrement attentiste dans les
dents linder et mandat vous occupez vous
voulez créer l'élan de mourenx et comme
j'ai chaque intérêt non vous êtes en
train de me dire que moi qui travaille à
mi temps qui est concerné qu'il n'y ait
qu'un mandat qu'il ait souhaité avoir le
mandat ou non expliqué qu'en fait des
élus écologistes sont les premiers
toutefois qu mais là je ne me parlez pas
d'écologie vabrais questions sociétales
des gens de votre parti c'est de savoir
si monsieur une partie de ma commission
la grande patrie mais aussi la grande
problématique des écolos qui fait de
savoir si monsieur placer la rentrée au
gouvernement sur l'emploi et aussi la
problème est plus des médias si je puis
me permettre
l'écologie du lac à table et c'est dire
on avance tous les emplois verts qu'on
peut avoir mais on a mené aussi une
politique très volontariste au conseil
régional avec le photovoltaïque avec
l'éolien ça permet aussi de créer de
nouvelles filières de créer des emplois
donc ne dit pas même l'avocat vous que
le legs ne votent pas alors que derrière
il ya vraiment un impact très positif
donc voilà il enchaîne j'enchaîne parce
que vous parlez julien 12 et c'est à lui
d'y aller poser la question suivante
c'était notre quatrième chapitre il faut
qu'on parle du front national on n'a pas
su vraiment parler encore et on entend
le passé en play vous l'avez qui marque
ce qui marque ces dernières semaines
bien sûr c'est qu'on ne parle pas du
front national sur ce qu'il propose en
politique mais uniquement sur le conflit
entre jean marie le pen et marine le pen
est ce que julien odoul c'est un conflit
freudien ou est-ce que c'est idéologique
autrement dit est-ce que l'antisémitisme
certains relents de racisme ce serait
uniquement jean marie le pen est pas le
front national ou est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça la réalité c'est que
jean marie le pen s'est mis j'irai au
ban du front national et qu'il a
souhaité malheureusement on le déplore
par des déclarations malheureuses basse
se mettre en dehors du front national
voilà la ligne politique du front
national elle est portée elle est
défendue par marine le pen
c'est une ligne patriote c'est une
souverainiste c'est une ligne social
c'est une ligne qui s'attache au
redressement de la france et je dirais
l'amélioration du quotidien des français
voilà après le reste il n'y a pas de
débat alors c'est vrai que depuis ton
bonnet mois mais durafour crématoire ça
a quand même plusieurs décennies donc
c'est pas nouveau vous dit jean marie le
pen s'est mis au bord mais jean marie le
pen ces propos là il les tenait déjà
c'est oui me demander quand des gens
comme vous vont au front national vous
êtes jeunes par rapport à d'autres et du
plus ancien vous connaissez dans marie
le pen vous le saviez donc c'était mais
j'arrive et je suis venu au front
national pour marine le pen voit le jean
marie le pen appartient au passé
pour moi ce n'est pas mon histoire ce
n'est pas il appartient à l'histoire du
front national l'avenir le présent c'est
marine le pen le front national sans
jean marie le pen il est plus dangereux
pour vous
pour les autres partis sébastien martin
je crois que la réponse elle vient pas
de regarder ce qui se passe au front
national ou rassemblements bleu marine
selon les circonstances
au passage la petite pme familiale est
en train de montrer que tuer le père
n'est pas simplement une expression mais
elle peut des fois venir ceux pratiqués
se concrétiser franchement moi je n'ai
pas pour en vie d'ici 2017 de simplement
positionner par rapport au front
national on a à défendre nos idées nos
valeurs nos projets nos programmes et
nos propositions et à faire en sorte que
les gens ils aient envie de voter pour
nous et pas en fonction des positions
des uns ou des autres qu'ils soient
socialistes verts front national ou
autre chose
c'est ça la politique la vraie celle qui
fait que les gens adhèrent et suivent
pas se positionne en fonction d'un rejet
d'untel ou d'untel
voilà donc mais on a le droit de parler
de tous les sujets de tous les sujets et
thématiques de tous les sujets que vous
n'avez pas leurs biens proposés dont
elle recommence je suis désolé monsieur
martin un mot sur front national je me
suis exprimé sur ce front national tout
à l'heure pour moi franchement il n'y a
pas de changement
il ya effectivement une volonté là
d'apparaître un peu plus propres est en
chute libre expression mais non sur le
fond il n'y a pas de changement monsieur
commencé son intervention en excluant
une partie des français contre une autre
vous avez parlé d'islamisme radical avec
lequel n'est pas une réalité deux
communautés accusé moi ce n'est pas une
réalité mais pas non non ce n'est pas
une réalité c'est une c'est une je dire
si c'est vraiment monté en épingle et
quelques syndiqués qui relaie une
communauté entière atteinte à la laïcité
à l'eneco tour communauté entière c'est
plus un million de midi en france ne
pose aucun soucis et vous excusez vous
excluez tout le temps donc non pour moi
ça n'a pas changé
vous surfez sur sur les probables vous
surfez sur les positions du front
national dans le programme qui exclut
les musulmans nos compatriotes musulmans
dites moi ni seule parole commencez par
vous n'avez voilà donc en tout cas voilà
pour le son voilà donc c'est juste
qu'effectivement si vraiment je me suis
dit je cesserai de me répéter c'est
vraiment comment redonner confiance aux
français pour qu'il n'ait pas cette
tentation de se sentir totalement
dépossédés de tout et qu'ils en soient
soit qiddissine moi je n'ai plus du tout
beauté ou quand ils viennent voter votre
viennent voter pour un parti qui prône
l'exclusion c'est vraiment la loggia
l'enjeu majeur l'enjeu société lors pour
la france il est vraiment là donc nous
avons une vraie on n'est pas là on va
pas de tous d'être nos politiques on a
parlé de ce qu'il faut créer de nouveaux
partis fort grave estime ainsi c'est
vous parce que chez vous chez vous
certains regardent beaucoup ça en
réalité on va dire syriza podemos et
l'implication citoyenne dont je parle
est effectivement c'est redonner du
pouvoir nous reste qu'une minute
démission oui juste pour dire que le
front national
effectivement ça n'est pas en tuant le
père que marine le pen va faire le
ménage
les idées sont toujours les mêmes le
programme proposé par le front national
c'est une franche de la france du repli
aucune proposition sur le plan
économique qui tienne la route
les élus quand ils sont élus votent
systématiquement contre tous les projets
il ya pas un projet qui trouve grâce
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui la réalité
donc le
objectif des responsables politiques
c'est de ramener les électeurs pour
faire des choix qu'ils soient tout à
fait républicains et que les
responsables répondent aussi aux
attentes des concitoyens sur le plan de
l'emploi sur le plan du pouvoir d'achat
sur le plan de l'éducation c'est là où
les français sont nous attendent je
viens de vous répondre et après les
infos 2010 parce que on parlera aussi
des élections régionales puisque j'avais
nous avions vendu aux téléspectateurs
plupart des élections régionales ce que
nous allons faire après les infos de
midi une poignée de minutes pour tout
savoir ce qui sur ce qui s'est passé en
bourgogne on se retrouve juste après